what is it doing to the rental market is
that one of the reasons why rents have
gone
up is that the airbnb market people
doing that is taking inventory out
so it's definitely taking inventory out
and i think they're being
very careful with uh not being seen to
do that and not doing it
but they're doing it they're doing it a
little bit how can they how can they
ever even claim that they're not doing
it so they're they it is happening uh
from long-term apartment rentals for
sure
but in the grand scheme of like what's
happened to our city sitting here in san
francisco with you and you know we're in
soma what's happening here is like i
mean it's zoning it's such a boring
answer but like i'll give you an example
thanks for doxing me
yeah now people know i'm in so much
founders it's so looking for me look at
the doors
my wife and i have a place in a dog
patch that we rent out long-term
apartment rentals yeah
lovely place near the new chase center
and the dog patch yeah
i want that to be massive development i
don't care what happens to my property
value it'll be fine
like they need to build there they have
capped building in the dog patch the dog
patch at four stories heights
it's so dumb it makes no sense san
francisco is so
dumb it makes no sense i when i'm mayor
mary jason.com i am going to tell every
developer
if you pay 10 years of taxes
in advance this year we
will let you grow grow your building
three times bigger
than whatever the regulation is now so
four is now 12. but you got to go get
some goddamn financing yep
and you got to pay me 10 years worth of
taxes today
then i'm going to take all that money
put it in escrow
to build better goddamn transportation
and finish this fukaka
bart system which they need to rip out
and start over because they use their
own custom sized trains
we need to use the standard trains from
europe and japan
and build a proper subway what do you
think of my plan would i get your vote
if i said
we're going high going to be some
shadows
some parks not going to have the same
amount of sun but we're going to get all
that tax revenue in advance to build a
proper
bart system that goes everywhere the the
barriers to going high
uh the the arguments are pretty weak um
if you look at what's blocking the thing
it's
shade it's one of two things it's local
associations who are protecting home
values
or it's the politics between san
francisco and sacramento where
cities don't want to be dictated to by
like the government of california
it is uh you know mayor breed said like
interesting stuff i want her to be riot
like rent control if you take that was
so well intended like rent control's
intention was amazing it was to protect
us as consumers and as renters
and combined with zoning laws and some
of the other things going on it has also
led to
the state we're in where there's just no
new supply on market and no one's moving
and we can't build enough supply i mean
we're building like a quarter of the
supply
but there are there is demand